good morning ladies and gentlemen my
name is John midscale I direct the East
Central European Center here at Columbia
University and I welcome you on behalf
of New York University on behalf of the
Harriman Institute and my own Center to
our conference on vista grab ukraine i
would like to begin with something that
we should say up front and that is that
this meeting would not be happening if
we didn't have such a good relationship
with our Ukrainian colleagues not just
downtown but in general and particularly
with Walter zelitsky who is the
co-convener of this meeting and who as
you all know last night had a very
successful session at the torch club at
NYU were most of you participated Walter
has been very active in Ukrainian
community and here at Columbia in
setting up conferences such as this one
and getting a variety of funders to
promote our activities and when I say
our activities i mean the activities of
the ukrainian studies program and the
Polish Studies program so our financial
sponsors for these events are the
Ukraine Ukrainian American Heritage
Foundation at mb financial in Chicago
Illinois the self-reliance federal
credit union in New York the Ukrainian
American Freedom Foundation the center
for us Ukrainian relations the Polish
American Ukrainian cooperation
initiative in Warsaw the critical
foundation in new york city and the
semper Polonia foundation in warsaw and
as you can see were particularly happy
to note that there's funding coming from
overseas to the united states which is
very different than the situation was
just a few years ago and an indicator of
positive change having said that let me
get down to business and thank everybody
for coming
I particularly want to extend my
gratitude to the diplomatic community
which has been obviously interested in
fishing rod and interested in fishing
rod at this moment in time when things
are changing things have been changing
of course for a very long period for
most of us at too slow pace and it was
just a couple of years ago when the for
fishing rod countries got into the
European Union that the leaders of the
four vision trot countries met in
chromis in moravia the Czech Republic in
May of 2004 that meeting they came out
with a declaration in which they stated
that with full satisfaction the key
objectives set in the 1991 viscera
declaration have been achieved and they
then declared their determination to
continue developing the cooperation of
the fishing rod room countries as member
states of the European Union and NATO
now having become members of NATO and
the European Union just a short while
before and after a very long and
difficult campaign to achieve this maybe
these four countries have achieved
division set out by President Vaclav
Havel in 1991 which was to expand
collaboration between
that have much in common with that after
decades of communism had little contact
among themselves and little experience
in political economic cultural and
security cooperation but after the NATO
and EU expansion happened 24 countries
were in the club so to speak analysts
began wondering whether in fact fishing
rod was an anachronism whether it's time
that passed what next other people let
me say with a more positive view of the
world pointed out that practical
regional issues still remain to be
solved in Central Europe and that these
issues could be solved only through
transporter collaboration such issues
obviously would include things like the
environment transport energy security
and infrastructure terrorism and illegal
migration and that's why the show
message declaration is important because
it explicitly states that the viscera
group the countries are committed to
closely cooperating with their nearest
partners in the Central European region
they are also ready to cooperate in
specific areas of common interest with
countries within the wider region with
other regional groupings in Europe as
well as
third countries and international
organizations so it seems to me that the
grip fishing rod for in 2004 reached the
same point in its institutional
development that NATO had after the
collapse of Soviet Union mainly it had
to either expire or expand and so its
members have been reaching out in
variety of ways to their largest
potential partner in the area you print
under Hungary's presidency this year the
bishop rod for sought to harmonize
bilateral programs supporting the forum
to organize high-level meetings that are
easy to communicate to promote Ukrainian
efforts at integration and demonstrate
the readiness to cooperate with Ukraine
and I have to say that these efforts
have really come a long way among the
fish across four countries let's take
Poland as an example Poland is witnessed
its relationship with Ukraine blossom
from one of polite understanding on the
elite level and mistrust mass level
during long period following Ukrainian
independence in the 1990s to one of
mutual respect and increased cooperation
at various levels of society today
polish NGOs were active in Ukraine prior
during and following the artists
revolution an event which I think you
would reproduce massive and
unprecedented outpourings of support and
understanding from both sides these
sentiments have served as the foundation
for a variety of mutually beneficial
activities earlier this week President
cutting ski visited president Yushchenko
in Kiev and trade and economic
cooperation regional politics and joint
projects in the energy
just really discussed they also
exchanged information about the
situation surrounding delivery of
Russian national natural gas to Ukraine
and they are the poles and Ukrainians
that is discussing other important
issues such as plans develop the oil
pipeline from voting in Ukraine to
what's in Poland and in fact later this
month an international consortium will
present the final version of its
preliminary feasibility studies for
extension of the Odessa Brody pipeline
and everybody hopes that this will
become reality in a relatively short
period of time since both sides have
been talking about this for years and
years and years another Idol efforts to
link the wide gauge railroad that now
connects I lesion with Ukraine to the
Russian Federation's railway system
which when combined with the
construction of a reloading terminal in
Poland would bring Poland into the
euro-asian railway transportation system
something that for the poles would be a
very good thing I think and then finally
for some fans of soccer a joint
application to the union of european
football associations join through
organized european football
championships and for a lot of people
who enjoy football that probably really
overshadows all the other so-called
important things that diplomats are
doing I don't have to say much i hope
with respect to trade issues of
regarding poland and ukraine right now
polish investors are looking at a
variety of opportunities in the
ukrainian market and in fact polish
business has been investing for the last
couple of years quite heavily there are
companies like
which produces beverage cans in Ukraine
the insurance giant has a boo a variety
of furniture producers which are now
building factories in Ukraine because
they can get both raw materials and
labor cheaper than a cannon poland and
they see of course variety of market
possibilities parquet floors are being
now produced in ukraine by a polish
company called bulimic and there are a
variety of other rather sizable
investments that have taken place and
it's not a one-way street ukrainian
business is also operating in poland and
so in the steel industry and also
automobile production Ukrainians have
invested quite a bit and trade is
growing the last number that I could
come up with was for 2004 turnover was
about 3 billion u.s. dollars which
perhaps isn't as a larger number as it
could be but there's a growth trend
there so this isn't a result I think of
direct state activity it's not something
that the fishing rod for are doing as a
group it is I think an outgrowth of a
vision of what the fishing rod for could
be doing with Ukraine and individual
countries of course are taking up a
variety of forms of cooperation which
are important both for Ukraine and for
the vision rock for let's remember that
the Czech Republic Slovakia Hungary and
Poland only know too well how entering
into the number
of multilateral and bilateral
arrangements can force economic
modernization can lead to increased
prosperity and also greater security for
all concern and what we do here during
our conference today I hope we'll
explore these issues and and of course
more issues let me stop and turn the
proceedings over to Professor on Jay
passion mobage the kosciuszko Foundation
Center for Learning Foundation
distinguished visiting professor of
International Affairs at Columbia
University who will lead the first half
thank you very much Thank You president
media good morning everybody lady and
gentlemen I have been covered in to
initiate our conference on if you should
cry in relation with our first panel
which will be devoted to diplomatic
dimension of this relation and we have
probably the best qualified people to
speak up this topic ambassadors to the
United States from Czech Republic mr.
that his successor collage and a muscle
of Kreider to to the United States the
solution sure they are both experienced
diplomats but they are also scholars so
excellences i invite you to be yes
possibly as a citizen as possible and
open with us in your statements of the
topic and now I give the floor to
ambassador czech republic to the United
States his Excellency Peter collage the
floor is yours Thank You professor lady
and gentlemen
I think this my gratitude I was invited
to speak at his girlfriend's Ukraine is
the topic which is for not only for us
but I think from the whole point of view
by censors day and I found I believe
that we had two very seriously
disgusting possibilities and challenges
which shall I in front of us
respectively or grin I i can speak our
sonographer I have limits about in n
minus versalife just finding cubism the
subject especially that exciting
especially for us quality exponent work
Ukraine is our neighbor I the beginning
should remind something what all you
never bites we live quite important
Michigan are four countries Poland
Hungary Slovakia Republic we all are
members of European Union and we all are
members of native and we all are
conceived great funds of transatlantic
so that's something what unifies and the
original group all be for michigan for
is again linked to our history to art
invested or corporations in facilitating
our countries which lead alerts and the
Communist era by interlinked and we
never actually were i would say full
style of Soviets top of communism
because we were satellites and we know
it means to be sudden I that one we know
what it means to be dominated from
outside by big neighbor so that's
another but important factors will be
mentioned in the beginning speaking of
achievement level as I would say that
they are for support if you grant from
her point of view there are at least
three basic reasons and all of them are
usually interlinked I would say the
first mission is a straight one well in
the past or not receive ensures and part
of the territory of Ukraine we know is
are quite well and the fact is as well
visually
regulations and now i Dessay even from
the current protected from the recent
history we are going to share google in
the same values and fulfill the in the
near future so that's historical reasons
then Chris quite important reason is a
reality as such if you look at that you
see that countries on the close to train
an inflamed is used country work it is
advised this could be the facts are that
busy as well and it would affect our all
these security to the past our business
so that someone swipes natural and Percy
be speaking we need Ukraine to be stable
prosperous and still appear in the
country I can still show that we
probably know accredited variants on our
Western countries in Europe because it
is people in from the past because of
our cooperation and bass the fact is
that with you if you just recently
look to to what was going on the brain
after the organ during the revolution I
think that first glance of mr. Solano's
very important but without President
passed new skin and president and uncles
ninja Bradley so successful especially
on Koshchei skill focus on the present
Poland will be played at that is
significant focus on moderator and is
very bad situation during constantly so
that's something was this led to the
reality reasons and then third main
reason is there is a principle the
question of the principle we really
believe that democracy and we just we
are living example that democracy is the
only way towards prosperity and rest
ability and this is our candy impressive
vocal society Czech Republic Slovakia
Poland and rain had a chance to the king
stable and democratic
prosperous countries who got a chance to
integrate themselves to the
euro-atlantic structures and thanks to
that we are also country's prosperity
today opportunities growing our people
are well optimistic mostly along the
best nature people of the magazine but I
mostly optimistically thinking about the
future so I think that this chance we
think of shoots and the Solidarity it
was shown to us from broth from Alice
Annika countries in Western Europe and
even from the united states that
mushroom the United States we should now
say is that true to help find from this
principal point of view I want you speak
little bit any more hugs the Czech
Republic as a design Lee and the vasila
czech republic
nice boxers from we shared our country
style we produce more productive as an
example of one be four countries issues
go stupid but definitely then I wanna
try to identify which are common folk p
for what we are going together that the
Czech Republic is broken is a let's say
they much property brilliant I can speak
about poker front listen of rarities
even from the respectability for because
that's how propriety in real estate what
happened three months ago I just worked
out that you do miss O'Connor person
actually that spot module also to create
accessible so I i can say that the
Ukraine is with one of the most
important priorities in our friend
policy we consider
important from the point of view of
stability and security in Europe and
then we really want to help you plan to
integrate you into Atlantic structures
me first respect you grant also from the
point of view of trade and investment so
again we think this is a country with
potentially it is immodest if prosperity
is growing and we should be helpful to
that then bursting purchasing power
parity will be granted means it will be
hopeful for our business community to
have such a la casa stable and growing I
once you say also that restaurant is
fantastic point of view within that this
part of the world it's so easy to
disturb his eyes that we saw what would
happen if the responsibility
is as it's not really i would say didn't
seriously what happened nothing in your
eve when the gas pipelines were closed
we're playing that's something what
really shouldn't happen in the 21st
century and things like that we should
we should avoid and that's reason why he
should Republican at the European level
but in the global as well we supposed to
desi discussion I'm Colonel approach
towards the necessary and Ukraine should
be very important part of this
discussion speaking about strategic
questions offers new security and so not
only that energy security security Asajj
and then for us it means that he had to
support an open tornado policy no state
sharing the user so late
we should be excluded from leadership so
that's something was for Ukraine is I
think for the future by the seneschal to
have this horrible nevertheless well
conditions are the same for everyone I
mean conditions of membership and
everyone must meet criteria for the
membership in NATO well so it is
essential that the necessary firms are
completed in Ukraine is uniform for
contents within democratic principles
and values but this is so easy to say
harder to do and we know that this is
really quite hard to do it vice / by our
own if you have no support so this is
this is something what we have two other
not only before that all the best
community that will do our best to help
you greatly diminished criterias and to
fulfill those conditions for the
membership so that's reason why we look
on the launch of the intensified elk and
Ukraine and patient named Amanda
and reforms necessary we consider
another even more intensified
cooperation what is the action plan for
leadership to be a logical next step
which should NATO take during this year
as a response to Ukrainian the phone
procedure as i mentioned criterias of
NATO membership are clear and the same
for all members so that that's fun to
say that really czech republic entire 24
countries but also the EU and NATO
countries found mostly able to provide
our support by altering our experience
and initially our experience especially
can be sheer effort from our
confirmation on forces but also
experience with meeting and fulfilling
other criterias in those political will
actually go great with Ukraine the area
of mine against
as well as other current problems and
fats like organized crime in immigration
s era it is mainly in the exchange of
informations as well as expert teams
corporation in 2004 an agreement and
mutual protection of stacy is inserted
the false so this is why i'm seeing here
is not a diplomatic by vengeance versa
fabric everything orange list of
interiors are cooperating our experts
and different levels from different
straight structures are in close
cooperation so we are just creating
social network of links and contacts
which is which really gives context
should be is this concrete as virtual
means and problems with every
transformation so it is basically i can
promise a that ukraine belongs to the
main recipients of our foreign aid
speaking about the check financed the
past few years the
the Czech Republic contributed various
projects with a lack of attention of
immigration silla service express
exchange and violent offending also by
almost two million u.s. dollars the
czech republic also contributed beyond
the UNDP especially intervention of
spread of hiv/aids and good governance
developments so the initiative for
organizations are actually I comparable
what was that in case of the Czech
Republic in Ukraine is almost identical
but I should mention some things which
are it reached a level of you go before
as well which actually somehow raise it
in details in some papers and some
documents between science and everything
portable decline so they can with our
members so we probably wants to
constitute and renders convenient
atlantic structures and we attempt to
make our support visible throughout
international community we were
intensified communication with the grain
representatives well just foil evidence
relations green nature / subject of NATO
ministerial means inconvenience for a
meaningful before prime ministers and
the brain in place Minnesota a son took
place at last last conference before
when ministers in Budapest formulas
mishchenko appeared last June semester
before privacy and fallen and so and so
and well we hope that after modulations
the current trend towards European and
to Atlantic structures will continue
whoever comes as a winner so that means
that being really now students shouldn't
wait and see we have to really work very
hard in any plane to have a dialogue
with all
all parties with all auditions were
there legitimately competing for window
there
elections so that's something what I
sometime can hear well if one side is
losing collagen so it means that being
should stop our support we should see
look well then i would say that we have
to be all arms folded where is winning
there this is legitimate democratic
process those questions are something
what's in that respect so don't get up
and village both politicians this is the
choice of Ukrainian people or their
politicians and we are not here to judge
it we are here to support it first well
as i mentioned risotto followed by mr.
mishchenko you know i can understand it
for some Europeans that was will be
confusing to see the pattern clash
between president Yushchenko panic
by this is really something what is the
Ukrainian convenient area as well and we
respect that the democracy has such a
from walsall time and it's natural so we
should have any here to make any
judgments became a comments maybe
judgments and we have to be really
respectful and supportive for these
collections was also quite important
initiative for is triggers to two cents
about 100 observers to my cell
development infections and then you need
to confirm me legitimacy populations and
if I'm a sunrise Watney check the
conditions are actually you're offering
besides the experience from our own
political and economic transformation
from the past 15 years respectively 16
years already we can we can first speak
about Steve so what we doing when we
were integrating ourselves a new
Atlantic a structures and such
experience to be used also for the in
creation of grilling free democratic
societies not only about institutions of
state it is very much about the society
essential we want you all to increasing
professional media reform of state
institutions first as something what we
are already doing that this is also
about education development
non-governmental sector vodafone's
economic and military transformation and
post what regards casa colina and the
we can also offer our experts and
because of you with the harmonization of
the law what is really a problem is
great i can say quite painful is it is
process and then of course we should
concentrate our for you to assist you
with the process of integration to those
structures which are named steering
again needle what we regard as
authorities to be hopeful first of all
be considered an introvert in 2006 a
garden as a complex implementation of EU
o iranian action plan we also got them a
new decision
guaranteed Ukraine discusses of
marketing only I think is also quite
important psychologically people
diversity in the Ambassador is tuna
years ago so it's really sad was it
important as well we considered
necessary to focus on economic progress
mainly finalizing WTO accession
negotiations and we under the throttle
sports stars of negotiations on the free
trade agreement between European Union
and Ukraine what is this quite specific
specific segments in this progression
between
in before report in your brain that's
the the fact that we designed and
realized some some aids of health
through the International Michigan phone
which is which is a seat in in
bratislava slovakia and it is a common
fund of trafalgar me where we try to
smoke especially some some senators as
important for development like education
and we offering scholarships and we are
sending some teachers to
universities has some experience so this
it's it's good assets but in this one
should be even more intensified and
should be growing because it's not
sufficient but it is an instrumental for
the beginning that it should respond
well making this should be also in hand
by some Western democracies I mean is
fun so I will conclude that now from our
going if you was really important is to
support not only politicians the lowest
end institutions but for NGOs for civic
society of them with and the adopting
some rules which are useful European
Union to help them decide Samsung
documents and books in your alien
language to give them all the Republic
of them organized and conferences and
seminars and support in regional
cooperation and some environmental
projects and also face and partnerships
which then on the municipal level would
be working very well that's that's the
experience which began also you know
politicians and I store sometimes
struggling and pickles I mean
international yahoo physical team to
another ship and you Michelle and not a
friendly sometimes be very tough that
people on the local level municipalities
mayors and even in geosenge operated by
very well so that's something work for
the already was important to have
something and invisible so monetary
policy issues of all it's trutv sugar or
for the front through the Sun and from
some other instruments which we have so
I will say as a conclusion that we know
that Ukraine is very important country
for all European Union
and 40 or we know that Ukraine has a
potential great potential to be and
become prosperous and democratic country
this is audiences westward mostly I I
think it's obvious they're even those
equal quality the eastern part of
Ukraine very even say baby wake up some
of them realize what is better and who
is your idol button so I think that
something was Holy Spirit reachable and
able to have a Ukraine as our ability to
visit in your advantage and it will take
some time it is not easy process it's
sometimes painful that it is a global
vision determination and dedication and
we also go to work hard all that then we
can do it you're here to be supported
not only
entering and speaking ability to be
released coated with you know the
mentors they're always on people as it
was palpable very very thank you very
much as muscle occurs from this video
chat positions of the drama its European
salvation and now let me give go to
ambassador for crying out in the United
States of America sslc on an assumption
and so well actually I would say there
is a certain problem when in this we get
together with our friends from this
event for on one hand it's extremely
easy because actually epson what was
said by my friend check ambassador is
something good to what I get angry one
hundred percent at the same time it goes
is the problem was I should say so I
would like to say and then I also had a
privilege of working on well as
relations with the Czech Republic but at
the same time also get some experience
previously i'm working on a mattress and
native so it's also given me a nice
perspective to see our preparation with
the sugar for in its amplitude english
so i would like maybe not repeat what it
has been said give a bit of history how
it developed and to draw attention to
some in my view important aspects of our
actual comprise
of course special diplomatic dimension
but also what to give my perception how
it might develop in future so first of
all I'm glad to say that for question
and in my view there was a stable
interest on both sides to force some
time some type of cooperation within the
EU and NATO aspirations context of
course at some stage this interest on
the part of Ukraine was great maybe than
on the part of day before and it were
the first proposed some kind of
interaction it was our initiative and we
had a positive response but quite
understandably the productive Capricia
was somehow hampered by the factor that
frankly speaking I EU and NATO
aspirations of Ukraine were quite often
more declarative and worse many
processes which have taken root in
Ukraine and special work on magnified in
two thousand sweet 2004 health made this
corporation that easy and productive so
in a way and very promising i would say
proved for enhanced cooperation which we
haven't seen since especially 2005 was
the well-known statement of fresh fish
before on this end of the cells of the
center in support of the democratic
processes magretta change in ukraine and
it was followed by very important
two thousand five ish Karen already
mentioned but I just would draw
attention to a very intense dialogue we
had in 2005 which actually involved all
levels of government under sleep or
national ready a meeting at the Prime
Minister's level which was even not
mistaken in July in kissimmee Stoli and
they had a chance to be there with Prime
Minister then there were meetings at
level of defence ministers and two
meetings attended by our Minister of
Foreign Affairs and it was very useful
that the last meeting also involved
representatives of Austria and Slovenia
so it is was even in a larger form I
would also like to mention that we have
seen a sort of the new function naked in
our cooperation with before by the fact
that it was but due to the fact that was
becoming more and more interesting and
productive it was a sort of the impetus
or maybe a sort of the catalyzer for a
new interest at the forge integration
between wave our triangle and Ukraine it
was mentioned actually yesterday I was
myself a part of launching the process
because I
our representative at the first meeting
which has taken place in Berlin at the
level of political directors and was
extremely interesting to see that as
soon as we've got some practical things
on the agenda and Charlie wait for
further development in a while we've
seen the it was the dreaded meeting
between the German Polish and Ukrainians
entities but it was as it was taken
morrissey practical practical form
fragile most immediately showed the
interest and to my knowledge this is
also taking shoppers some pace and some
speed but coming back to before and the
in-plane generation while the actually
would say would like to see why it is
important so from our perspective so
first of all of course is a matter of a
political support of Ukraine's
inspirations to join the european union
and nate and i would say that we have
found among the members of before and
also post baltic states the most most
persistent promoters of ukrainian cause
when she didn't hesitate to pull this
matter before and they continue to
discuss and put for those issues even
now and at the time one maybe if you
take in you the climate is no
the most religious but we've ever I
should be sheet that this argument is
being for it by our colleagues from
before secondly I think that it's very
important that I we have some bread
practical input from our cooperation
with Michigan before and first of all it
has been made within the framework of
our implementation of action plan in the
European Union at this stage we have
already had proposals from practically
all I guess from all visible for
countries to have a practical input in
the plains of limitation of action plan
to the European Union and the price of
this planet like underscore sincerely
well is extremely big because it's quite
clear that in this is imprint doesn't
have a possibility to fail because the
implementation of the action plan and
successful limitation of the blender
will be a sort of power and I will see
the strongest argument increasing with
European Union as to a further
enhancement of our bilateral relations
and of course and welcome is it would
define the form of the new enhanced
equipment which we hope to start
negotiating may be tested leo
this year but definitely we would like
to see in the well accomplished by the
time when the action plan expires and
the partnership and cooperation expires
as well veho again make it on the topic
of discussion to see this enhanced
agreement uniform which would be as
close as possible to the Europe to
so-called Europe association agreement
giving a clear management perspective of
what impression of course is not is less
important in our cooperation with NATO
as I said they found in the before and
Baltic States the most vocal supporters
of our quest for native membership and
again we had speaking not simply about
political support but also some concrete
a cooperation in addressing different
aspects which around at 4th hour
training native and in this sensor also
like to say that he think that 2008 for
obtaining the invitation to generate you
is realistic in struggle and we hope
that we will carry the day so thirdly
what is important for us in our
preparations before in general and
special of those two matters is that it
can done best experience of the v4
countries on their way to EU and NATO
and it's important that of course
experience of such a country as well
let's say let's take countries of the
latest wave like sadness of course in
principle can be useful as well but the
posture is no comparison
perience of v4 countries because we have
had definite similarities and of course
being can learn from both positive and
negative experience of course it's very
unfortunate mostly we learn from our own
mistakes but it is to try to learn from
somebody else's mistakes could be
extremely important one additions where
I think we should be looking very
carefully at your experience would be
the issue of winning the public support
for you and especially nation and is
very muchly problem a lot of newspapers
well actually because his corazon will
be extremely important to look at the
ways baltic states and before while
dealing with issue which was an issue in
many countries before they started a man
distraction when but definitely also not
to be discouraged by low levels of
support we have now people dissociation
as I was told by many friends from me
four countries was not that Rosie in
those countries at this at this
catchment you were embarking upon the
road to edu and special native mansion
it's also important for us to see this
kind of I would say the to have the
right
again from yester instances right
balance of incentives and impediments to
in our movement to European Union and
native a very important thing which I
think facilitates our interaction with
before is that i would say address
mutual interest you were absolutely
right to say that before receives very
well the importance of the brain for
stability in many senses in all senses
in europe especially in Europe Central
and Eastern Europe but I would like to
see that is also if we go and look at
the diplomatic dimension we also see a
synergy of interest because in my
perception active Eastern policy of
vision reform in general and individual
enhances distance of this group and
countries who shall be part of the group
within Nate within the European Union
and the European politics so there's a
mutual interest and i think that the
only solid route for any relationship is
mutual interest it's also very important
economically although i do not want to
encroach on the other topics but it's
also important that here we see very
active movement in two directions not
only that trade is growing in well from
v40
on Ukraine to be four and what is even
more important some our big companies in
big groups are issuing quite impressive
in positive terms investment policy in
before countries we think typing product
is extremely important that i would also
like to say that what is also good with
a going back maybe a good farm
experience side it's also a very good
debt before we have developed so far
given that she needed to have a straight
over dialogue again again maybe relate
in my personal experience when I was a
governing Prime Minister too busy news
Tony what the main event is a gradient
delegation was a lunch at level of prime
ministers and what was important ed
lunch that apart from some of the usual
good field talk there was a very
sobering precision on the quarter before
prime ministers of the guard association
the European to give you great Arab
perspective what should be done and not
to be discouraged by this situation and
how to pursue the best of european union
membership and meaning and not to
exacerbate the difficulties but rather
to use the situation and maybe to pursue
more nuanced policy of many issues so i
think it was extremely important and i
haven't been present at meetings of our
defence and foreign minister but i
presume the dialogue was more or less
along the same lines it's also very
important that we have very good synergy
of efforts and
the method was mentioned very important
aspect that not only our governmental
actors but also non-governmental actors
are becoming more and more active in
their context it's also important that a
part of the huge institutional
cooperation meaning between before as a
group and Ukraine as a country we have
also their intensive a dialogue at the
level of bilateral relations between
ukraine czech republic in grandpas and
other members of a v4 so in a way i
would say i'd only one hand a bilateral
creates the necessary groundwork or the
web of necessary bilateral relations
which helps to cooperate more
intentionally and more productively at
the group level so giving group and in
great but at the same time thick
operations with the group engine crane
is a sort of amplifier sending rising us
at the palestra so it's very interactive
process I won't don't want to sound
shell and say that it's works perfect
love what we are entering in a way the
initial phase of this kind of
preparation but what we have seen from
the gradient perspective so far was
quite promising and if I go back to the
diplomatic part of our discussion I
think that our liberation busy for both
and Burlison
group and Ukraine was also helpful and
helping to forge better if you wish
diplomatic relationship and interaction
with european union because discussion
of some matches of importance with v
forth helps us for example to define
more quickly and more deadly position
concerning some statements move of the
european union and the fact that we were
so successful in German statements of
the European Union I don't remember what
is the rate right away but it was
definitely over ninety percent joining
statements of the European Union was
also to a very great extent to the fact
that he had been discussing some
problems before this before countries
and can obviously not advice from him
for embassies in your brain if necessary
added actual caps to integrate your
brain into the process of diplomatic
coordination within European Union and
NATO plus it also helps to work
individually in the sense that many
initiatives we have been discussing
recent with individual members like
pollen from sample hundred some others
is definitely helpful in the long run so
final ish we should like to
dressed very quickly that's of course
the issue of energy security you
mentioned this one would likely to be
even more important issue in our
interaction and one of the example is
Odessa broad of course many receive it
in view of the original context as
mostly Ukraine polish enterprise but as
it transpires it becomes more and more
important without the active involvement
of other than four members for example
began an interview to this issue in this
thing which was discussed for seconds
some went up as some quite time I mean
the so-called test transportation of oil
to grow locally and it's an important
element for the success of the pole axis
as meaning on energy issues I think that
interaction of all man was looking for
and Ukraine Israel becoming even more
and more important and he felt he works
with the right that we are huge on the
same line of wyatt when the problems
with guess if i started in january 2005
so meaning that really is really
important that he coordinate our policy
and stick together did instead was
possible so let's a couple source i
wanted to share with you and
thankfulness yeah I thank you very much
ambassador
your statement and intervention due to
discipline of our panelist who still
have few minutes great off for answers
questions and answer sessions and I see
but yeah and he will be next no me queda
microphone nothing sephora in ukraine
were the only protagonist in its own
internal development and promise then
the form that you have been discussing
me for plus you pray would lack urgency
but the problem is of course that
Ukraine's eastern neighbor is a direct
protagonist in this process both
structurally and is made its of one as a
matter of policy as the owner of late
that policy has taken a
matic brutal form and that suggests
night suspect ambassador tion Shaw
agrees that this form must think of
waste of becoming more focused more
institutionalized more integrated more
intense and that is accentuated by the
fact that as you both applied NATO the
EU are both very large very complex very
divided institutions and some forum
within it is needed as a clearinghouse
determinate ER of ideas so my question
is do you see merit in either another
prime ministerial meeting or a summit
well compare was a general would be to
review the existing mechanisms that
exists and strengthened and possible
either economize on them all expand yeah
first of all I I don't want employment
with you the European Union and NATO
first they are because the air in
different members of this of this
structures some time showing that they
have like a different interest that's
true and there are bigger countries and
small countries the fact here in the
United States for example
I realized that the European Union is
not respected by often like the like the
one buddy it's always now pick up some
bigger countries some powers from
European Union so that's that it
reflects reality because from my point
of view I think we should really take
seriously the European Union as a
structure which should offer the
perspective for Ukraine the NATO also
should offer the perspective for your
frame and the fishing business for
that's the as I mentioned before RHP we
we are with all four members of Michigan
are members of NATO and European Union
we don't want to create some inner
structure inside of those organizations
we are the regional group like
Luxembourg October together with Belgium
and Netherlands know that something was
good work inside it doesn't mean that
this is the alternative the cooperation
with Ukraine is essential for us because
we are they and then the actual and the
doorsteps of Ukraine and Uranus on our
doorsteps we are affected directly if
this space is disposed of course we also
learn from our experience that the
spread of democracy is the best way how
to spread this catalytic also and that
is not only ukraine there is also be
nervous which is what a special topic of
today discussions and the international
level and so our are just my perspective
is that we as a fishing report we have
to represent the same time the interest
of European Union or actually lecture
sometime or to help aren t you partners
and the importance of Ukraine better to
to be helpful as those who are having
personal experience with transformation
and offer our experience to Ukraine what
we are doing actually we can do it even
more and to create some well currently
instituto nacional de session is the
most important thing for them but first
vista graph for other instruments of the
regional cooperation as a instrument of
kind just you know as a bridge to to
pass our experience from the recent
years and to offer our mistakes as being
while speaking about it to give chance
ever your friends friends to learn from
it that's that's the best way of what we
can do meetings of our prime ministers
of our ministers of manifest our
politicians or statement that's fine and
we will do this and we can do it and
across the exchange of their views is
important for all of them but i would
say even more important is to on the
expert level to offer concrete support
of a concrete experience and to have our
people there and to invite Ukrainian
people to our institutions to give them
chance to learn something from inside
and actually the target is the
membership in European Union and when
the ship in NATO European Union is this
is more complex problem and it will take
some time it took us well most 14 years
before we became the member of European
Union from the day by be restored our
democracy and it could be in Ukrainian
case even longer but it doesn't mean
that we and NATO is a another issue
it doesn't mean that we should resign
for that we should Billy Cochran and
sundry to incorporate Ukraine in so many
activities of you na dou as as possible
so that's that's my mind you I think you
are really interested more in the EU
membership in NATO membership and
Reformation well we shall see but I
would like to see where is the Cygnus
has to be short so I think that for us
before is a forum of real original
cooperation with the special emphasis on
EU and NATO membership so it's most
important for us is really to use it in
a positive sense of course to full
extent to getting really hurt and
prepared to even enter membership one
meetings I think for me is quite clear
that it would be extremely useful not
simply have a meeting or assignment as a
I would say one in them but to have it
more or less in regular basis to have an
institutionalized because I think there
is extremely important but of course to
make them as practical as to the point
as possible was not to lend it to some
few good exercises but discuss really
important
imagine for example energy so how we
should complete almost on general things
and some practicalities of which for
example have been discussed for some
time but actually so the question is
rather a comment in regard of NATO I'm
afraid that the Polish experience a
second slower environment million simply
different in regards of promoting NATO
for poles there was no problem with
accepting polish membership NATO but I
work in you crying and I pretty
convinced that there is completely
different situation which which is not
compatible so I remember myself when I
was in don't buzz about few months ago
and to manage to make a survey at the
University of dogmas among the students
of the political science international
relations we asked simply two questions
the first question was are in favor of
Ukraine joining you and are you in favor
of Ukraine gentleman named and can
believe that about eighty percent of the
students were in favor of Ukraine
journey EU but also eighty percent of
them was we're against the NATO members
I can easily sorry i can easily Magnus
exactly so I understand that Ukraine
needs to develop the completely new
strategy and the Polish Hungarian Slavic
cannons
check experience in the regard of
promoting NATO is not applicable to your
pride so just this correction very great
with that a yes was it would be foolish
to say that our we'll see internal
situation is the same that were what you
had before and any other countries right
here at the same time looking at your
experience items again it's my opinion I
don't what can be used first of all the
ways you were operating more or less
technical the outreach to public opinion
with all the differences how do work I
mean the government level how in work
with stress and we have to think very
careful now because we cannot issue
techniques saying that NATO is good
compared to what has no said before so
we is to learn how to work a special
example so technical things plus
speaking about native experience of
course how to interact with native
bodies what will be the right messages
to send but all these having said I
didn't speak about that but it's quite
clear that modal if you wish allow
integration into a NATO and EU
definitely it will be different from
what has been 4v four countries I'm not
speaking about the job right ear that
basically with the DC but the engines
and things you have to resolve would be
welcomed as in substantial differences
all words and speaking about
experiencing speaking about some
practical first so the pressure system
last question
I realize culture doesn't occur anywhere
in a program that I'll take the
opportunity for cultural diplomacy and I
was the vice president of the
International Association of appraising
studies which did surveys of how various
countries how much study goes on
Ukrainian how much knowledge goes on and
in that I find tremendous differences in
the mission direct form from Poland
where knowledge of Ukraine Ukrainian
studies information on Ukraine has
boomed in the past 15 years to the
bottom of the core the Czech Republic
where it is actually declined that is
the amount number of people studying
pregnant or interested in Ukraine carry
on the field material available and
check on Ukraine has not increased at
all and I wonder to what degree observa-
s interrogating this opportunity what
degree if the future of this content is
decreased and impact of the vision graph
for our but evident packed in Ukraine
the time has come perhaps religion those
cultural policies I admit on the other
hand course knowledge of Ukraine of the
Czech Republic is a business but the
general knowledge of hopefully the
difference is in very bad shape but I've
been surprised at the lack of attention
to culture language learning
the block is going to be more well I
know they excrete I just emotionally I
can say any chance you know your brain
once we just want us to split the
slovakia that you're going to smell the
neighbor country anymore so it's
probably faculty psychologically the
velvety greenville from the other hand
we have many Iranian citizens in our
comfy living and working very neat we
can't live without ethics which is so
important to our economy especially to a
petrol universities additive
perseverance that it shows I think it
would be it would be 12 is a process
because they are sitting now some of
them there I mean well presently in our
hospitals you know you can see so many
nurses very cleaning in construction
industry and convenience and they are
working some work and controlling and
going bad and just many will never
sustain and it's something for
probability fact even in fact it turns
studies and universities well the
problem is that I I think you know what
if I don't register lately what happened
in between words and so forth person she
was over Republic because that's I'm
very small part of Ukraine was about to
not hear me actually and he had a lot of
Ukrainian index
so then escaped from the Soviets Suez
Ukraine and we're teaching in
universities and our choir was a quite a
strong Ukrainian intellectual group in
progress in our cities so the background
is there I think it could be developed
in the future quite easily I don't just
are not here to make any planning and I
knots ability to make a predictions but
I guess naturally it will develop
because Ukraine is becoming visible
country we have a lot of Ukrainians in
our in our country from even from the
business point of view it's becoming
very interesting so people from business
would look for someone who speaks
Ukrainian language who knows Ukraine so
the that's something what the market you
know is situate pushing to work it will
it will it will be it will be done from
the down side from the upstairs I think
it's just up to the universities and
they I think that in the faculties of
art and philosophical faculties there
are people who are very supportive for
four uranium studies I know some of them
and just surprised I didn't know about
the statistics that its decline or it's
on the same level firstly the Polish
case is very different because they you
know if you if you know know what to
happen with the Polish Boris after
or two it's really obvious in our face
reading Spratly not so intensive one
more last wish yeah knowing that all of
this is being filmed for posterity and
that we are going to put it on the on
the site John promised me that i'm going
to ask this question pretty bluntly of
the both ambassadors and that is the
concept of v's god who created a core 5
I know that I got in trouble two years
ago in one of these forums when I asked
that you can am ski to speak to you
Europe they told me that it was an idea
that it had time had come and gone there
was Rumsfeld's sort of old dream but it
didn't go anywhere was an American dream
that I'm going to come back to that
issue again given the fact that the
energy dimension has come into it I'm
going to ask from a diplomatic
perspective isn't it possible that uh
that Ukrainian music God can conform a
core 5 that can speak to the issue of
what may be a very very threatening
situation given that the greater and
greater dependency on one single
supplier and that supplier is a supplier
to the north given the instability in
the Middle East and so on and so forth
it's more and more that if not Western
Europe certainly Central Europe and
Korea are going to be under the sort of
shadow got strong for a while is there
something on a diplomatic level that
might bring the five together to to
bring these issues up on a on on the
international forums or as a group is
that possible or is that just sort of
that concept of you Europe really is a
very concept they are there that Europe
can democratic Europe Eastern Europe can
work together and and and really have an
influence in the in the world sorry
about that but
and so very missing suggestion I'm not
hearing the capacitive speak about this
kind of planning but I think what is
situated the relative the fact that we
are somehow squeeze some time because of
the lack of resources for mon energy at
home it could leads to some hard
cooperation and high level and the
before plastic rain I think on some
clothes maybe those discussions are
already going on you know the fact is
that energy security this is just issue
of the recent recent masses and I think
before some people before they realized
that it was not very visible subject in
politically days now it's becoming quite
different the problem is that even in
European Union we are not unified about
energy security issues and about energy
Asajj we have their nuclear Lobby like
France Netherlands czech republic
finland granted kingdom when we have a
su countries like Ireland or Austria
which are very much against in her
energy and we are struggling something
inside of European universe
diplomatically and politically
struggling and some time is really quite
strange to see the neighbors like the
Czech Republic in Austria could disagree
very much about the goat yogurt your
energy with Ukraine I think situation
became more visible because what
happened after the new year eve its
tactical so Austrian example and we
learned something about some Austrian
things like franchise and other things
you know this is something what of
course this is the new subject I hope
you're absolutely preferred to to say if
really we are now into and a high level
to coordinate so much it we should
thanks I can be also their short saying
that I'm not a de planning department
either all the time being but definitely
I I will personally like to see more
discussion on energy issues within this
for me but to make it really meaningful
it should be a part of the large
European discussion on how to secure
Thank You lomachenko muscle is not
interesting contribution I think we have
we've had very good fun Island this is
promising start to continue with the
next panel and I propose that we will
start next on without a break just now
yeah thank you